hello America this is President Barack
Obama let me be clear I am the first
president ah periscope it's America's
favorite actor Tom Hanks and welcome to
my book club where all the books are
about war oh yeah I like to take these
opportunities to talk about stuff I'm
really passionate about you know like
fighting those Ivor's I owe I never seen
the movie with that taupe guy Pierce
it's like amazing you know awesome
hello this is sorry McKellen oh no
wonder where I am there's the camera
it's your favorite tall drink of water
of incentive on people always ask me in
real life Vinnie are you a ladies man my
man you know I am a bit a bar right now
I'm inside a bar I'm gonna give you some
inside tips about how to get your tip
inside you know what I'm talking about
baby
ah let's try some questions and I will
answer them okay these are just racial
slurs what did you play what do you got
Oh coffee man I ain't into that brother
man I'll uh I'll have a pop proud Muslim
loser loser you're fired
wait what that's right you're fired
because you're a loser let me tell you
something welcome to Tropico it's my
version of periscope except it's
obviously way more luxurious my PR and
things so I need to periscope you know
kind of get you yeah I'm gonna shut you
prick I'm trying to be put no you're not
being a professional like yeah yeah I
never said I wanted Magic Johnson to die
I just think he gives us an unrealistic
perception of what it's like living with
AIDS sitting here in baby food for lunch
gotta eat baby food because real food
makes my stomach culture just Cana we're
up okay I said I'm not gonna answer
questions about true detective we're
talking about the ladies right now I'm
in a bar right now do you want to have
any come on Lady quite
okay here's what about Rachel McAdams
because she's on true that I'm not
answering that one dating Gargoyle is
611 your working-class American you work
at I have I would never work at I happen
let's say I did if I did Trump would be
the greatest rooty tooty fresh and
fruity deliverer of all time you're a
loser you're fired
califor is did a drunk hello African
children anything on this menu what's a
croissant